are we
ready Judas and his
salvation was Judas saved no he wasn't
how do I know he wasn't say John
17:12 our Lord in his high Priestly
prayer pretty much says that he didn't
lose anyone that the father gave him
except the son of predition son of
predition Son Of Destruction John
17:12 okay while I was with them in the
world I kept them in your name Those
whom you have you gave me I have kept
and none of them is lost except the son
of predition that the scripture might be
fulfilled that phrase son of predition
only refers is only used one other time
the phrase son of predition is only used
twice in the New Testament twice in the
New
Testament once here of Judas and another
time of the Antichrist the man of
lawlessness the man of sin 2
Thessalonians
2:3 2 Thessalonians 2:3 but you guys got
to listen and be attentive to see where
I'm going with this because you're going
to be in for a shock and surprise just
be patient help me to help you and
listen Okay second Thessalonians
2:3 this is used of the man of
lawlessness the man of sin the man of
Satan filled with Satan empowered by
Satan the Antichrist here it is 2
Thessalonians 2:3 okay let no one
deceive you by any means for that day
will not come unless the falling away
comes first and the man of sin is
revealed the son of
predition the son of predition there you
go the phrase son of predition is only
used twice one of the man of sin the man
of lawlessness the Antichrist who's
filled with Satan possessed with Satan
whom Satan Works through meaning he
belongs to Satan in other words this
phrase shows you that like the
Antichrist Jew Jud belonged to Satan and
like the Antichrist Judas was
destroyed okay John 670 to
71 John 670 to
71 now read with me guys razel read
Jesus
answered them did I not Choose You the
12 and one of you is a devil say I chose
you the 12 but one of you is a devil he
spoke of judas's car the son of Simon
for was he who would betray him being
one of the 12
so we see here Judas is a devil he
belongs to Satan right he's a son of
predition okay now with that said does
that mean Jesus never desired the
salvation of Judas does that mean Jesus
never wanted Judas to be saved does that
mean Jesus did not love Judas no are you
guys ready for a shock now are you guys
now ready to for me to show you the same
Jesus showed he loves Judas desired
judas's salvation and glorification and
even told Judas that he was dying on the
cross for his
sins are you
ready are you
ready razel are you ready because this
is your question okay razel this is for
you Matthew
19:28 Matthew 19:28
Matthew 19:28 so Jesus said to them
watch here now Jesus said to them
assuredly I say to you that in the
Regeneration when a son of man sits on
the throne of his glory you who have
followed me will also sit on 12 Thrones
that's the TW Apostles one of whom is
Judas you have followed me will sit on
12 Thrones that includes you Judas
judging the 12 tribes of Israel oh my
goodness Matthew
19:28 that was my older brother sale
he's big and ugly and if ugly was a sin
him and Frank would have to serve
lifetime
sentences
okay Matthew 19:28 one more
time again to Judas Jesus said to them
assuredly I say to you that in the
Regeneration when the son of man sits on
the throne of his glory you have
followed
me will also sit on 12 Thrones judging
the 12 tribes of Israel folks 12 Thrones
12 Apostles 12 Thrones 12 Apostles one
of whom is Judas do you see what Jesus
told Judas my desire for you Judas is
that you sit on one of the 12 thr
Thrones with me in the Regeneration when
I restore the Earth and I come in glory
you who follow me will sit on one of the
12 Thrones judging Israel because that's
what I desire for you that's what I want
for you Judas no Paul did not replace
Judas Gary Paul did not replace Judas
maias replaced Judas in Acts 1
21-26 okay was Jesus
lying was Jesus lying or did Jesus mean
it from his heart because he's God and
cannot lie that Judas I want you with me
in the Regeneration on one of the 12
Thrones judging the 12 Tri of
Israel so razel do you see the Heart of
Jesus for
Judas now let's go let's go to Luke 10
17- 20 Luke 101 17- 20 Venom's my guy
Jews believer in Jesus who did a great
Batman skit but he had to remove it
because of ser serious Muslim issues
anyway Luke 10 17 to 20 then the 70
return Luke 101 17 to 20 guys pay
attention then the 70 return with Joy
saying Lord even the demons are subject
to us in Your Name Lord even the demons
are subject to us in your name 70
returned one of whom is Judas Judas came
with the 70 saying Lord demons submit
themselves to me when I use your name
Lord now notice what Jesus says in Luke
10 18 to 20 pay ATT mention specifically
verse 20 and he said to them I saw Satan
fall like lightning from Heaven behold I
give you he's speaking to all the
disciples Judas is there I give you the
authority to trample on serpents and
scorpions meaning evil spirits demonic
spirits and over the all the power of
the enemy and nothing shall be any means
by any means hurt you now watch here
watch here guys 19 and 20
verse 20
nevertheless do not rejoice in this that
the spirits are subject to you but
rather Rejoice because your names are
written in heaven okay Luke 10:20 one
more
time Luke 10:20 one more
time okay nevertheless do not
rejoice in this that the spirits are
subject to
you but rather Rejoice because your
names everyone present Judas included
are written in heaven do you see the
Heart of Jesus even for Judas whom he
knew was the son of Satan with betray
him Jesus Is Telling Judas I love even
you I desire your salvation I even have
your name written because my desire is
for you to be saved but unfortunately
being a son of Satan you will abandon me
reject me and betray me and not return
to me and go to your
destruction but then it gets even better
because then Jesus tells Judas even on
the cross when I die I die for your sins
but you don't benefit from it because
you don't receive because you don't
believe truly Luke 22 19- 20 and he took
bread and gave thanks and broke it and
gave it to them saying this is my body
which is given for you notice no
qualification
all of you here this body represents
that I'm breaking my death that I'm
going to die for you okay this is my
body which is given for you do this in
remembrance of me now notice verse 20
likewise he also took the cup after
supper saying this cup is the New
Covenant in my blood which is shed for
you doesn't qualify it he doesn't say
not all of you some of you most of you
all of you except one this cup is a new
comeing of my blood shed for
you and who who was there when he said
for
you Luke 22 21- 23 notice who was
there but behold the hand of my betrayer
is with me on the table so Judas is here
with me as I said these
words and truly the son of man goes as
it has been determined but woe to that
man by whom he is betrayed then they
began to question themselves which of
them it was who would do this things did
you catch
it this this bread is my body broken for
you this cup is a New Covenant in my
blood shed for you and yet the hand of
the betrayer is here on the table so
wait Jesus when you said that you're
including Judas so Judas heard you speak
to all of them him included saying to
all of them him included I'm breaking my
body for you you to Judas I'm shedding
my blood for you you two Judas and yet
one of you is going to betray
me one of you is going to betray
me in other words what Jesus is showing
is the audacity the travesty the
blasphemy that even though I'm gonna die
for this one and shed my blood for this
one to procure his Redemption showing my
love for him to the very end he will
still betray me anyway and spurn my love
and reject
me in spite of all I've done for
him exactly Jesus loves all exactly
Jesus loves all you're
right did you catch it in other words
you're supposed to see the travesty the
audacity the blasphemy of a man hearing
Jesus say to him and looking right in
his eyes I break my body for you I shed
my blood for you yet nevertheless the
hand of the betrayer is on the table
with me that's how you're going to repay
me that's how you're going to respond to
my love that I love you to the point of
dying for you and how do you respond you
spit in my face and you sell me for 30
pieces of silver oh Judas what more
could I have done for
you
right it's touching isn't
it so why did Jesus do it so why why
then Jesus did you die for Judas KN he
betray you let me explain the logic in
that number one to show that Jesus truly
loves all his creatures even though who
reject him and condemn themselves to
hell and number two to show how
righteous his judgment is when he judges
them in spite of all he has done for
them in other words do you now blame
Jesus for consigning Judas to hell in
light of What Judas did you understand
this now shows how just God is in his
judgment that I did this all for you
Judas you slept next to me I hugged you
I kissed you I fed you I clothed you I
protected you I even gave you power to
do miracles in my name to raise the dead
in my name to cast out demons in my name
and then I shed my blood for you and
this is how
you repay
me and this is what you
do you understand so now when you see it
from that perspective is Christ
thoroughly just and condemning Judas to
Everlasting
destruction see it's even moving me in
my spirit it's moving me in my spirit
right because I can understand when
Jesus is looking at him see it's moving
my
spirit he's looking at him and he knows
you know what you know why it's moving
me let me break this down let me bring
out the implication guys let me bring
out the
implication okay let me let me bring out
the implication
from day one when Judas came Jesus
looked at him see it's actually moving
me it's moving me my spirit Holy Spirit
take over for the glory of Christ he
looks at a man and Jesus knew from the
beginning this is my
betrayer this is the one who's going to
betray me for 30 pieces of silver this
is the one who's going to be filled with
Satan and he's going to hand me over to
the chw to hand me over to the Romans
because of his betrayal they will beat
me to a bloody pulp and whip me to the
point of death spit on me beat me with
rods place a crown of thorns and then
nail spikes in my hands and feet hanging
on the cross gasping for life it's all
because of this man is going to betray
me and he knew it and you know what he
did Welcome
Judas welcome sure you can follow me
[Music]
come on of course
Judas you're more than welcome to be
part of my Apostolic man and all he did
for all those years of ministry was love
him bless him be gracious to him kind to
him provide for him feed him clothe him
and even if you go to John if you go to
John chapter 12 it says that Judas was
in charge of the money bag guys let me
blow your mind away a little more can I
you guys really want me to go deep on
this you want me to go deep on this you
guys really want me to go to deep see as
I'm thinking about it my heart is
breaking it's really moving me in my
spirit to talk about this it really does
when I talk about this it moves me in my
heart
okay John 12 says that Jesus even in
trusted Judas to the money bag you know
what that money bag means it means that
Jesus was not ashamed to collect
donations for Ministry guys let this
blow you away Jesus who's God Almighty
humbled himself to such an extent that
he depended on the financial support of
his followers to keep him and his
followers in
Ministry do you know that how many you
guys didn't know
that Irene already answered that
question go back did you know that don't
take my word for John 12 and you know
what John 12 says it says that Judas
used to help himself to the money he
would steal from the money bag but
here's what's mindblowing here's what's
mindblowing Jesus knew that Judas was of
the devil Jesus knew that Judas was
stealing from the money bag Jesus knew
Judas would betray him and he never said
a word to him never rebuked him never
embarrassed him he let him do what he
did till the very end when he betrayed
him in fact it's even more mindboggling
that in John 13 if you read the chapter
say Jesus got off the table removed his
robe put a towel and he started washing
the feet of the disciples and he washed
the dirty feet of Judas who in a in a
moment would be dwelt by Satan knowing
that he's going to betray me tonight
tonight he's going to betray me and he
still washed his feet
you see how amazing his love
is you see how amazing his love
is if I knew this man was going to
betray me if I knew this man was
stealing I would insult him I'd ridicule
him I may even beat him to a bloody Pope
or he'd have to beat me up Jesus knew
this is my
betrayer who's going to betray me for 30
pieces of silver he's going to steal
from the money of the ministry people
giving from their money to my Ministry
he's going to steal that's okay I'm
going to love him till the
end I'm going to love him to the end and
that's what he did